and starting on Thursdays couple this
Thursday should say couples can fly into
Las Vegas Tie the Knot Before ever
leaving the airport the Clark County
clerk's office will be opening up a
pop-up marriage license office over at
Harry Reid International this is
actually the fifth year they've done
that there's so many people that come
into town to get married on Valentine's
Day so that pop-up will be open daily
until the Valentine's Day which is the
14th lovebirds can speed up the process
by filling out the marriage application
before they arrive and literally just
get your piece of paper when you arrive
at the airport